it's been a hundred days since russia
invaded ukraine so let's hold on for a
minute and look at the cost and death
and destruction this war has caused it
is almost unimaginable the united
nations says that more than 4 100
ukrainian civilians have been killed
that includes more than 240 children
thousands more have been wounded and the
u.n says both numbers are likely to be
much higher with areas like mariupol
still inaccessible
it's also hard to know how many soldiers
have died russia hasn't released any
figures recently but the uk's defense
minister says at least 15 000 russian
soldiers have been killed there's also
little information on how many ukrainian
soldiers have died but ukraine's
president says between 50 and 100
fighters are dying every day
the war has also pushed millions from
their homes the u.n says more than 6.8
million people have left ukraine since
the war has started some have since
returned and millions more are displaced
within the country
and then there's the destruction more
than a thousand schools and hundreds of
hospitals iron ruins in addition to
houses roads bridges and factories it's
widely agreed that the cost to rebuild
will run into the hundreds of billions
of euros
i'm now joined by our correspondent uh
rebecca ritters in kiev rebecca an
absolutely devastating 100 days for the
ukraine but is it going to get even
worse
well gerhard
you know almost nobody here believed
that this war was going to happen now
here we stand 100 days into the conflict
and the conflict is entering a
particularly grueling phase
on thursday jen stoltenberg the head of
nato
warned ukraine and its allies to prepare
for the long haul
to prepare for the grueling war of
attrition
as he calls it and that is certainly
what we're seeing play out in the east
of the country as we know
kiev was the big prize for russia when
they stormed in here on the 24th of
february they wanted to take the capital
and instill a new government
they failed in that everyone thought
that kiev would indeed fall within 72
hours but as we now know
ukraine managed to hold out to push back
russian troops from the capital then
russia of course regrouped and moved to
the east and that's where the fighting
is taking place today we are seeing
this grueling war of attrition play out
there as russia slowly does advance
we're seeing some gains just to give you
an update of what's happening on the
battlefield we are seeing some gains
ukraine managing to to take back little
pockets and areas but it it's very very
small back and forth russia not making
huge uh inroads now but they are looking
like they will take that key city of
several donetsk in luhansk and be able
to perhaps take lysi chance the sister
city on the other side though that does
remain in ukrainian hands at the moment
once they've done that they will be
really in control of most of the luhansk
region of that area and they will then
try and take parts of the donetsk which
make up that donbass region which is now
their main aim uh in this war
so rebecca the hundred days of this war
much much longer than expected how do
you explain this
resilience of ukrainians
they're incredibly uh resilient i
suppose i mean that word is always a bit
difficult in these terms in these kind
of situations i mean what choice do they
have really they they're being they're
being invaded and they they have to kind
of stand together and unite and try and
and fight back
but they have proven to be incredibly
resilient and you know what is perhaps
surprising and certainly pleasing to
most ukrainians is just how much they've
united behind the war effort uh since
it's begun you know you really you
hardly hear anyone being critical of
what's going on here
everyone's sort of behind backing uh
president zielinski even those who may
not have voted for him or may not have
been happy with him as going into this
war they now stand behind their
president they're very happy with the
way that he has been handling the
situation the way he's been rallying the
international community and uh you know
that is something that is really helping
with morale here
rebecca you've been covering that war
nearly since the very beginning what are
the more lasting impressions
uh well there are several i mean i was
here in the country a couple of weeks
before the war broke out actually and i
went home thinking oh this isn't going
to happen like many people here most
people told me we've been in a war
already for eight years we don't believe
that that putin is going to send his
troops in and try and take the country
but we were all proven wrong and uh i
would say that the lasting impression
really is that unity that i'm talking
about you know
ukrainians really united pooled together
and it's really an incredible thing to
see another thing that really strikes
you when you're here i mean particularly
in kiev uh is just this sort of
juxtaposition this sort of sense of calm
in the city at the moment i mean
obviously that wasn't the case as troops
were surrounding the city but now you
know a couple of months into this war
and has pushed back troops there is a
sort of calmness here life is returning
almost to normal in the capital though
at least it's got a sense of normality
to it and that is is really strange to
think just a couple of hundred meters uh
kilometers rather down the road you've
got all of this
you know death and destruction on the
battlefield so that is another really
kind of um oddity of war
rupert is there reporting from keefe
thank you rebecca
and as rebecca mentioned the fiercest
fighting is now centered on sierra
donetsk in the donbass region in a late
night video address on thursday
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
gave this assessment of the situation in
the east of the country
the situation in donbass has not changed
overnight we've had battle success in
seviero donetsk but it's too early to
tell how it's going the situation there
is tough as is the situation in nearby
cities and towns such as lesi chance
bachmat and others
the russian army uses all of its
available armed capabilities
speaking there now for more let's cross
over to our military analyst uh frank
lloyd wright who joins us from oxford uh
in the uk frank i'd like to ask you the
same questions that i asked rebecca
earlier uh is this going to get worse
for the ukrainians
well let's look at things in the larger
context the russians went into this
wanting a war of annihilation which
would take 15 days we now know that was
their planning assumption and what
they've got is a war of attrition that
is likely to take
one or more years
on the plus side of the ledger they have
taken the city of mariopol on that
southern coast which does threaten
ukraine strategically but on the
negative side and rather more
significantly for the moment they have
essentially reduced the conflict down to
that donbass area which is now their
immediate objective an area they've been
looking to take for the last eight years
and are focusing really their entire
combat effort on that so that's where we
are now
talking about that region fighting is
now concentrating uh concentrated there
especially around the city of sierra
donetsk
how decisive is this battle in the grand
scheme of things
gerhardt i think this is one of many
battles to come it's even one of many
battles in this phase
what the ukrainians are doing is using
the opportunities in several donetsk to
a treat russian forces something they've
been doing now for the last three months
grind them down continuing to dish out
casualties and what they're not doing is
treat it like a fortress city as they
did in mariopol
which when they had to do that anyway
so this is not the
sort of end battle the last battle or
even particularly decisive they will as
rebecca said move on to lissa schansk
and possibly even further as president
zielinski said uh further west so it's
one of many battles even in this phase
so frank many including yourself when we
talked about uh this topic earlier uh in
in in the war was you were surprised at
the let's say underperformance of the
the russian uh military at the outset uh
resulting in heavy losses um
have they learned from their mistakes
now
well as one general said recently if
you're going to learn under fire indeed
learn at all and there's a whole field
of study of military learning you need
two things you need a solid training
culture
and military professionalism all wound
up and uh directed by excellent
leadership
and the russians have none of those
things the raw material they have is
extremely poor and it's getting poorer
as they're taking further casualties it
does seem that they're learning
something but
you know if you're continuing to feed
virtually untrained personnel in large
numbers or perhaps not even as large as
they need into into a grinder then
you're not going to get a good result so
russia is learning but but not very
quickly and that's why it's making the
same mistakes again and again again lack
of professional culture
now ukraine said they prepare for a
counter-offensive
sometime in june losing donbass now
recapturing it later uh is that a
feasible strategy
well gerhardt i'm not too sure they will
lose all of don back don best they will
the uk ministry of defense it has to be
conceded said today they're likely to
lose the luhansk area whether they can
move on to take the rest of uh into into
donetsk is highly questionable
um but um but we are where we are that's
the current objective and
i suspect what will happen is at some
point in the next few weeks russian
momentum will will stall and they will
declare some kind of victory which
places the initiative then in ukrainian
hands again
our military analyst frank ledwich there
thank you very much frank
thank you gerard
now ukrainian prosecutors say they've
identified thousands of cases of war
crimes committed by russian forces
during the invasion they include
execution-style killings the rape of
women and children and torture
authorities in kiev are determined to
bring the perpetrators to justice as
dw's terry schultz reports there are
means to do this but it will not be easy
a warning this report contains images
some viewers may find disturbing from
the start
[Music]
one hundred days of war
more than fifteen thousand alleged war
crimes and a crime scene spanning
virtually an entire country
butcher
earpin
car key
international investigators want to see
the perpetrators in another city as soon
as possible
the hague
we all know who are responsible for this
war for these deaths for everything what
is going on in ukraine of course it is
president of russian federation and his
team
actually who started this war who
started to kill civilians rape
civilians tortured civilians alleged
atrocities which if proven are war
crimes while the prospect of actually
getting vladimir putin and his military
commanders into a courtroom may seem
remote ukrainian prosecutor irina
benedictova has unprecedented resources
to reach that goal i
feel i trust and i hope that with my
international colleagues with
international
community of lawyers we can speak about
justice we need justice
we want accountability
a new joint investigation team
headquartered in the hague is
cooperating to seek justice in a range
of settings in ukraine where there have
already been convictions in the
international criminal court the icc
which is gathering evidence on the
ground and in at least 10 european
countries using a mechanism called
universal jurisdiction
i think this is what is needed for
crimes of the magnitude that we often
see at the icc we have to join hands in
the common interest of humanity evidence
from the various investigating teams
from ukraine or other national
governments to the international
criminal court will all be deposited
here at eurojust the european union's
judicial cooperation agency then all
authorities will have access to it but
even with these joint efforts war crimes
cases could take many years because of
their extremely high burden of proof
human rights lawyer lotte liked explains
there's a quicker path to justice
prosecuting the crime of aggression
it is a crime where leaders
people in leadership positions make
the decision
to launch war against another country
every bomb in ukraine today every
shelling of a city
or a town
every tank of a russian tank
in active in ukraine is a crime of
aggression liked supports calls for
another tribunal to be set up to handle
these cases likely under the human
rights body the council of europe
ireland the council's current president
wants to do that by november
how much patience do ukrainians have to
see war crimes prosecuted irina
benedictiva answers by recalling the
horrors she's seen on the battlefield
it's impossible to forget it's
impossible to forgive in other words as
long as it takes
german chancellor olaf schultz was quick
to brand the ukraine war a turning point
and this week he announced new weapons
for kiev a hundred days into the war new
poll numbers are out showing what
germans think about their government's
response
29 say the german government is not
giving enough military aid to ukraine
while 42 think it is adequate 23
say the assistance goes too far the
number of people answering adequate is
up seven percent from april
well for more on these latest poll
numbers from germany let's bring in dw
political correspondent hans brandt
hunts how has german public opinion and
the government's position evolved
well we have to see that 100 days ago
when this war started there was a huge
wave of support in public in the german
public and across the world of course
for ukraine hundreds of thousands of
people went onto the streets to
demonstrate in favor of ukraine and at
the same time hundreds of thousands of
refugees from ukraine
started coming into germany and other
countries in europe
so this
this initial wave of support um still
continues but as the war has become
longer and more complex so has become
the response the response in germany and
amongst german politicians as well as
well has become a lot more complex
at the moment there is not just the
question of supporting ukraine but the
question of how to
support ukraine and much of the issue
centers at the moment around the
delivery of weapons what kind of weapons
should go to ukraine and to what extent
that would mean that germany and other
countries in the western alliance would
get involved directly in this war which
obviously they want to try and avoid for
the german public at the same time
effects such as inflation are making
themselves felt so in german public
opinion um there is some uh hesitancy
now about how this
how the the matters are proceeding at
the same time i think what you have to
say is that in general support for
ukraine remains very very substantial in
german public
okay of course this
a big part of the shift involves
people's view on russia let's look at
some of the polls other findings germans
were asked what stance the government
should take towards russia when it comes
to supplying ukraine with weapons 50
percent think germany should take a
tougher approach while 43 say berlin
should not do anything that would
provoke russia that's a slight increase
from two months ago the poll uh also
asked about sanctions on russia 41 think
the measures don't go far enough 37 say
they are adequate while 15 think these
sanctions go too far
hans uh tell us more about how german's
attitudes towards russia vary across
party and regional lines
yes russia is obviously uh
the central issue as it were
in in all of this and
one can see that in the german political
spectrum
support against very strong measures
towards russia including
weapons supplies sanctions and
diplomatic efforts
is strongest among the supporters of the
green party which is a surprise because
that party has
something of a pacifist past
whereas the other government the major
government party the social democrats of
chancellor olaf schultz their opinion is
somewhat more split with people
certain democrats feeling
that russia should not be provoked
this goes across to the far right of
german politics uh the alternative for
german germany party uh which has a lot
of support for russia and is critical
very very very critical of government
of the government's stance towards
russia and then if you look at the
regions in germany the east of germany
and the west of germany the former
eastern germany former communist eastern
germany surprisingly one might say
support for russia there
remains much stronger than in the west
there people still feel that russia
should be
in some sense respected and that one
should be careful about provoking russia
the feeling is possibly that
russia
used to be in communist germany
an allied country and there might still
be some feelings of
friendship towards russia there at the
same time there is also a lot of support
for the right-wing alternative for
germany party in eastern germany so that
overlaps i think with some sort of
respect for authoritarian rule
which one sees in russia
two's political correspondent hans grant
thank you hans
you